the dallas cowboys have a franchise
quarterback in dak prescott the problem
is his contract has expired and some
decisions need to be made stephen jones
cowboys ceo and son of owner jerry jones
said tuesday
that it's been urgent for us to get
prescott signed we certainly want to get
that done that's our number one priority
as we go into the offseason now look
peter the analysis at this point is
pretty simple the franchise tag
non-exclusive level will be at about 26
million for this year if they go
exclusive franchise tag to slam the door
on anybody trying to sign into an offer
sheet and give up two first round draft
picks to get him it's going to be north
of 30 million those become the starting
point whichever tag they choose that's
the starting point for a long-term
contract and the numbers get very big
very quickly but this guy's earned it
right there are plenty of guys who are
lesser than him at the quarterback
position who are making a hell of a lot
more money than what i think they could
have signed him for during the 2019
season and as you said before and you're
absolutely right you always pay less the
sooner you sign a guy and now they're
gonna have to pay
a lot more than they would have liked to
have paid in order to get this done
otherwise he can just go year to year
and he can say
hey i'll be kirk cousins tag me once tag
me twice you won't tag me a third time
and i'll go sign a contract on the open
market even if the team he signs with on
the open market is the dallas cowboys
yeah i i just mike i would just make
this point to the dallas cowboys
that
what happens right now if you go to dak
prescott's agents
and you look at that chart you just had
of 35 million and you just say listen
let's multiply 5 times 37
okay
and we'll put say 60 or 70 percent of it
will be guaranteed just just let's just
say you're going to make 65 of the
contract totally guaranteed
and it's five years averaging 37 million
and everybody would say oh my god dak
prescott doesn't deserve it blah blah
blah blah it doesn't matter
it is monopoly money
signing in march
always costs less than signing on august
30th
it makes no sense to drag this out the
cap is probably probably going to go up
monstrously in 2021
anyway
so you take a big hit this year
and then in 2021 you're back to where a
quarterback should be and you know where
that is mike at about 15 or 16
of your total cap which is not painful
well and again i'm waiting for one of
these quarterbacks to be able to
negotiate a term where he's guaranteed
to be paid x percent of his contract
throughout the course of the deal to
protect against the ongoing
uh increase
right right of the cap rather all right
yeah 15 18
i'm guaranteed to get that much
every year uh so that when the cap goes
up my salary goes up accordingly and i
never get to a point where i feel like i
have a bad deal because the cap has
passed me by and the market's passed me
by but look he's got a ton of leverage
and the cowboys have to acknowledge it
if he wants to play hardball he can
screw things up for the cowboys not that
he would but he could and peter if he'd
decide if they tag him and he decides to
go the le'veon bell route and shows up a
week before the start of the regular
season and signs his tender and says i'm
ready to go
it's going to make it hard for mike
mccarthy in his first year as the
cowboys coach to get the most out of his
team
no question about it that's why it's
incumbent on the cowboys to go the extra
step right now
this year in march get it done put a
self-imposed russell wilson style
deadline
on this because mike mccarthy needs on
april 6 the first day of the cowboys
off-season program you know the new
coaches get two extra weeks
mike mccarthy needs dak prescott to be
learning and to be his leader in the
locker room every day
that's why they gotta get it done when
the league year starts
simple deadline the deadline for
applying a franchise tag that's what
worked for the ravens and joe flacco
seven years ago and that should be the
natural very real deadline for the
cowboys and dak prescott that's it for
wednesday's pft live peter great work as
always with siri back here again on
thursday have a great day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports